"Uncatchable", Alexandr Zhelanov
...
-George Arthur Forrest,
vous vous dites africain blanc.
Qu'est-ce qu'un Africain blanc ?
-Je me définis
comme un Africain blanc
parce que je suis né là-bas.
Je me considère comme un Africain
mais je suis blanc.
-C'est incontestable.
-Ce serait difficile
de dire que je ne suis pas un blanc.
Mais je reste africain.
-Vous êtes né
au Congo dit belge.
-A l'époque en 1940.
-Et vous avez acquis
la nationalité belge,
si je ne m'abuse, en 1995.
-Exact.
D'abord, j'avais
la nationalité néo-zélandaise.
-Ca, c'est l'histoire
de votre famille.
-Voilà, et comme je me suis marié
avec une Belge à l'époque
qui est décédée malheureusement
très jeune, qui était belge,
j'ai demandé la nationalité belge.
On faisait les affaires
avec la Belgique,
on y allait régulièrement,
c'était en Europe.
C'était plus facile d'être belge,
ayant fait mes études en Belgique.
-Mais au fond de vous-même,
vous êtes africain ?
-Profondément.
-Congolais.
-De République
Démocratique du Congo.
-J'ai vécu tout le temps là.
Et toutes nos activités sont là.
-Avez-vous souffert
du racisme pour autant ?
Des Noirs vis-à-vis
des Blancs.
-Personnellement, non.
-Non, jamais ?
-Non.
Jeunes,
on jouait avec des Africains.
-Vous alliez à l'école
avec des Africains ou...
-A l'époque, pas trop.
Mais les quelques-uns
qui étaient là étaient de bons amis.
On discutait avec eux,
et ils m'ont appris la langue.
-Vous parlez plusieurs langues ?
-Je parle le swahili.
-Hakuna matata.
-Ca veut dire
"pas de problème." D'accord.
-"Jambo bwana", "bonjour monsieur".
Vous parlez swahili couramment.
-Couramment.
-Et vous le parliez
dès votre plus jeune âge.
-Dès mon jeune âge. Et les Congolais
qui parlent en swahili,
je parle en swahili avec eux.
Même les autorités.
-Et quand il y a eu moults problèmes
en République Démocratique
du Congo,
qui s'est appelée le Zaïre,
du temps de Mobutu,
vous avez vécu, notamment...
Kolwezi.
Et cette prise d'otages,
Kolwezi,
en 1978,
où on sait que l'armée française
est intervenue.
Vous avez pas craint
pour votre vie là ?
Ce qu'on attaquait,
c'était les intérêts occidentaux.
Les Blancs.
-Effectivement, ils ont attaqué,
mais ils sont venus chez nous.
Quand ils sont venus
me faire prisonnier,
ils ont voulu m'exécuter.
-"Ils ont voulu m'exécuter " ?
-Ils m'ont mis au mur,
ce sont mes travailleurs qui m'ont
sauvé en se mettant devant.
-Vos salariés zaïrois ?
-Ceux qui étaient à la maison.
-Ils vous ont sauvé ?
-Ils m'ont sauvé, exactement.
-Sinon, ils voulaient vous tuer.
-Ils disaient que j'étais
un ami de la France, de Mobutu.
-Un "sale colon".
-Un capitaliste,
pas nécessairement colon,
mais capitaliste.
Après, bon...
Comme mes travailleurs se sont
mis devant, ils ont été étonnés.
Ils ont demandé qu'ils se retirent.
Et de fil en aiguille,
j'ai pu placer quelques mots,
dans la langue, en swahili.
Donc on a eu un dialogue.
Et ils m'ont dit :
"OK, on attend,
on va demander au chef."
Quelque temps après,
ils m'ont gardé prisonnier.
Et j'ai été gardé comme ça
avec une quarantaine de personnes.
-On vous en voulait
parce que vous êtes
un homme d'affaires,
à la tête d'un groupe économique
important, qui a été...
Dont les fondations ont été bâties
par votre grand-père, votre père,
et vous,
vous avez développé tout ça.
Vous êtes présent
dans le domaine bancaire,
dans le domaine minier,
dans l'aviation.
-On était dans l'aviation aussi.
Dans l'agro-industrie...
-L'agriculture ?
-Bâtiment.
-Vous êtes dans tous les domaines.
On a été dans plusieurs domaines.
Là, on s'est limité à 3 domaines.
L'énergie,
BTP, les routes,
et euh... l'agro-industrie.
-L'agro-industrie.
C'est à ce titre-là
que vous avez... Parce qu'on
estimait que vous étiez riche
et que vous exploitiez finalement...
-Mais également,
mes travailleurs sont intervenus,
car les travailleurs chez nous
vivent dans de bonnes conditions.
Nous faisons beaucoup de social
pour la population.
Nous avons des hôpitaux, des écoles.
Nous soutenons beaucoup de choses.
-Pour développer.
-J'ai été éduqué comme ça.
Mes parents disaient : "Quand
un pays t'apporte quelque chose,
"il faut redistribuer
une partie à la population."
-Vous vous définissez
comme un Africain blanc,
et y a un président qui est mort
qui s'appelait Bongo,
et qui a écrit,
"Blanc comme Nègre". Euh...
Y a quelques années,
c'était en 2001 ce livre.
Vous l'avez connu ?
-Je l'ai rencontré quelques fois.
Un homme remarquable,
très sympathique.
-Qui a pourtant
une image en Occident
et en Afrique,
pas toujours excellente.
-Nombre de chefs d'Etats africains
sont mal vus en Europe
ou en Occident.
-Mais en Afrique, ils sont pas
toujours bien vus non plus.
-Non, mais Bongo était bien vu.
Vers la fin, il avait une image
qui était dégradée.
-Vous avez écrit un livre,
"Un Siècle de rêves".
Disponible aux éditions
du Cherche Midi.
Vous y décrivez tout votre parcours,
le parcours de votre père,
de vos aïeux, en Afrique.
Et vous êtes un de ceux qui disent :
"L'Afrique,
c'est l'avenir de l'Europe."
Qu'est-ce qui vous permet
de dire ça ?
-Parce qu'en Afrique,
on trouve tout.
Y a les mines,
y a les réseaux hydrographiques,
un des meilleurs au monde,
particulièrement au Congo.
On a toute cette richesse.
Y a les forêts.
On trouve tout ce qu'on veut
en Afrique. Il suffit
de le développer, d'avoir une bonne
volonté avec une bonne gestion.
Que reste-t-il en Europe ?
On a tout délocalisé.
On n'a plus rien.
Point du vue sous-sol,
on n'a plus grand-chose.
-Oui.
-Point de vue industrie
manufacturière,
presque tout a été délocalisé.
Et on se demande
ce qui va se passer dans le futur.
Or, le futur était l'Europe.
L'Europe avait de bonnes
relations avec l'Afrique.
Des entrepreneurs
investissaient, développaient.
La création de l'emploi,
c'est la diminution de la pauvreté.
Les gens aimaient rester là-bas.
Les gens voulaient pas
forcément partir en Europe.
Maintenant,
on parle du rêve européen.
Mais peut-être que demain,
on aura le rêve africain.
-Des Européens iraient
s'installer en Afrique en masse ?
-Le jour où l'Afrique
va se développer,
avec ou sans l'aide de l'Europe,
elle va se développer.
-Vous êtes sûr de ça ?
-J'en suis sûr.
Des gens viennent
de plus en plus de bonne volonté.
Vous avez une classe moyenne
qui a quitté l'Afrique.
Ou des intellectuels
qui font de brillantes études.
-Etats-Unis, au Canada,
en France, en Angleterre.
-Même position à l'extérieur.
Mais ces gens ont envie de revenir.
-Ouais.
-Mais le jour où ils reviennent,
où les autres vont rester,
ils vont développer chez eux.
Et vous verrez
que ce pays va repartir.
Toute l'Afrique
va repartir en force.
Le Congo particulièrement
et toutes ces richesses qu'elle a.
Si elle avait une bonne gouvernance,
on arriverait à développer ce pays
de façon magistrale.
Mais il faut autoriser aussi
qu'il y ait des investisseurs
qui viennent,
qu'ils respectent les lois.
Plus il y aura d'investisseurs,
plus on aura une meilleure éthique.
Car les entreprises sérieuses
qui viennent d'Europe
ont une éthique
qu'ils doivent respecter.
On est surveillés en Europe.
Donc en Afrique,
il faut faire pareil.
Mais il faut aussi, dans ce domaine,
que les banques
puissent suivre et accompagner.
-Elles jouent pas le jeu ?
-Plus aujourd'hui. Au contraire.
-Les banques européennes ?
-Oui, et quand je vois en Belgique,
ils ferment les comptes
des résidents africains
et particulièrement congolais.
D'un côté, on dit :
"Investissez en Afrique."
Et d'un côté, on dit le contraire,
on fait le contraire.
Dites-moi un peu,
comment voulez-vous développer ?
Est-ce que ces banques
sont complices avec les Etats
ou l'inverse,
pour maintenir l'Afrique en état
de pauvreté pour des raisons
qui leur sont propres ?
-L'Occident maintiendrait
l'Afrique en état de pauvreté ?
C'est vous qui dites ça, incroyable.
-Même les conflits
qui se passent là,
s'il y avait
des développements du pays,
on n'aurait pas tous ces problèmes.
Avec une bonne gouvernance.
-Mais justement,
parce que vous dites,
l'Afrique a cette richesse,
une démographie incroyable,
donc une main-d'oeuvre...
-Elle a cette jeunesse.
-Elle est jeune.
-Cette main-d'oeuvre
est intéressante.
-Moins de 25 ans de moyenne d'âge.
-Si y a développement en Afrique,
vous avez toute une main-d'oeuvre
à disposition, qu'on n'a plus ici.
-Mais vous avez mis le doigt
sur quelque chose.
Vous parlez de mauvaise gouvernance.
C'est pas de la faute,
si ça se développe pas
des chefs d'Etat,
des leaders africains ?
-C'est pour ça
qu'il faut développer.
Plus y aura d'investisseurs sérieux,
moins y aura de corruption.
Et automatiquement, y aura
une meilleure gouvernance.
C'est ça qui compte.
-Vous avez été victime
de la corruption ?
-Oui, on est là,
on a tous ces Chinois,
ces Asiatiques, Indo-Pakistanais,
qui débarquent au Congo,
les Turcs aussi maintenant.
Chez eux, y a aucune règle.
-Oui.
-Donc la concurrence
est compliquée.
-Les Européens
ont des règles éthiques.
Les Chinois, les Turcs
se moquent des règles éthiques.
-Oui, parce que chez eux,
y a pas de problème.
-Mais les problèmes de gouvernance,
Par exemple, le président
congolais de RDC,
mais on sait que y a régulièrement
des accusations de mauvaise
gouvernance en Afrique.
C'est une des raisons,
faut pas le nier,
de cette Afrique...
René Dumont disait
qu'elle était mal partie.
-Oui, mais je suis convaincu
que si on revenait...
Je reviens toujours à créer
de l'emploi sur place,
les gens ne partiraient pas.
Donc y aurait une meilleure
gouvernance aussi.
En plus, il faut former les gens.
Y a plus tellement d'éducation.
Et un pays sans éducation
n'a pas d'avenir.
Il faut remettre
l'éducation en place,
les soins de santé
et l'auto-suffisance alimentaire.
Si on arrivait à développer ça...
Ne fut-ce que l'éducation, déjà.
Des gens éduqués
vont pas accepter
tout ce qui se passe.
Or que, c'est facile de maintenir
un Etat dans un état de pauvreté,
ou dans un état d'autoritarisme,
si y a pas l'éducation.
Je crois que
c'est une des bases à développer.
Et ça, vous avez des pays
qui ont bien compris.
Si je prends l'exemple du Sénégal...
-C'est un modèle pour vous ?
-La Zambie. Depuis quelque temps,
c'est un modèle.
Avec une démocratie
bien respectée.
Y a d'autres pays
qui se développent avec force.
-Combien de salariés
avez-vous M. Forrest ?
-Actuellement, plus ou moins 10 000.
On a diminué de la moitié.
-Sur le territoire...
-Congolais.
-Vous avez diminué de la moitié,
pourquoi ?
-On a été nationalisés
dans les mines,
donc on a perdu les mines.
-Y a eu des erreurs de gouvernance.
Vous étiez dans un pays
qui s'appelait Zaïre longtemps.
Y a eu la "zaïrianisation" du pays.
On dépossède les propriétaires
de leurs biens.
-C'était la grande erreur de Mobutu.
Les 5 premières années du pouvoir,
il a été fabuleux,
le pays repartait très fort.
-Mobutu Sese Seko. On va le voir là.
Il est là.
-Voilà.
Quand il a créé
cette zaïrianisation,
mal conseillé, car il a voulu créer
très vite une classe moyenne.
-Au tournant des années 70 ?
-Oui... 73.
Il a voulu créer
une classe moyenne très vite.
Il a dit :
"On va distribuer les biens."
Ce qui était une erreur.
Parce qu'il a décapité
toute l'économie,
et toute l'infrastructure
qui existait.
Et depuis ce moment-là,
le pays a commencé à sombrer
dans les ténèbres, comme
aujourd'hui, où c'est terrible.
-Le Zaïre
ne s'en est jamais relevé ?
-Jamais. Parce qu'après,
ceux qui ont suivi n'ont pas essayé
de redresser le pays.
-Kabila, père et fils.
-Le père était un idéaliste.
Il a toujours cru
que le pays était très riche.
Quand il s'est rendu compte,
il a été assassiné.
Le fils, euh...
Il avait d'autres idées.
Son conseiller ne l'a pas aidé.
Ils ont fait avec 2-3 expatriés
et toutes sortes d'autres personnes
une corruption maximum,
dans un intérêt purement financier.
Donc...
Ils ont fait venir
tous les Asiatiques, les Chinois.
C'était plus facile
de travailler avec eux
qu'avec les Européens.
-Je suis investisseur français,
belge, allemand,
je veux venir en Afrique
en République Démocratique du Congo,
que dites-vous pour me persuader ?
-Je dis qu'il ne doit pas hésiter
de venir, parce que y a moyen
de faire beaucoup de choses,
avec une main-d'oeuvre, pléthore,
et qui n'est pas si chère
par rapport à l'Europe ou ailleurs.
-Elle est pas exploitée
cette main-d'oeuvre ?
Exploitée sur le plan financier.
Elle travaille beaucoup
mais on lui donne peu.
-Je dis "exploiter",
c'est leur donner de l'emploi
correctement.
Avec des bonnes conditions.
Mais y a des domaines vierges
qu'il faut développer.
Y a un potentiel énorme.
Si je prends l'agro-industrie,
tout est à faire.
Nous avons commencé
l'agro-industrie,
il y a quelques années,
mais nous avons maintenant
presque 4000 personnes
rien que là-dedans.
-Dans l'agro-industrie ?
-Oui, on a 60 000 têtes de bétail
sur un million d'hectares.
On a 10 000 ha de maïs,
1500 ha de soja.
On va commencer le blé maintenant.
On a une biscuiterie
qui produit avec les capacités
qu'on peut mettre, on arrive
à 36 000 t de biscuits par an.
Donc ça fait quand même...
Aujourd'hui,
rien que pour la région de Katanga,
on produit
plus d'un milliard de biscuits.
-Vous êtes pas handicapé
par le réchauffement climatique,
la sécheresse ?
-Non, parce qu'on a un climat
qui est très bon.
On peut dire ce qu'on veut,
on a quand même deux saisons.
Mais y a de l'eau partout.
Donc y a l'irrigation
qui compense le climat.
On choisit ce qu'il faut
pour les plantations nécessaires,
en fonction du climat et des terres.
-Oui.. Mais y a quand même
un climat assez anti-occidental.
Assez anti-français, anti-belge,
en Afrique aujourd'hui.
C'est pas quelque chose
que vous redoutez
et qui pourrait faire
que toutes ces exploitations,
tout ce que vous dites,
les Africains disent :
"C'est à nous tout ça.
"Les Européens ne doivent
plus gérer ça."
-Il faut faire participer
les Africains.
Vous pouvez leur donner
une participation aussi.
Y a moyen de trouver des formules.
-Ils en ont chez vous ?
-Ils ont des participations.
Donc euh..
Il faut choisir le juste milieu.
Comment développer
ses activités sur place...
Ce sentiment anti-occidental
qu'on a, comme vous dites,
provient déjà par le passé.
L'erreur qu'on a faite...
Déjà, on était conquérants.
On est arrivés
comme des donneurs d'ordres.
On a supprimé toues leurs coutumes,
leurs traditions.
-Ca, c'était une erreur ?
-C'est une erreur.
On a imposé nos religions.
On a imposé nos coutumes.
Or qu'il fallait
leur laisser leurs coutumes,
leur religion,
mais développer le pays,
en respectant leur traditions.
Je crois que c'était
quand même important.
-C'est l'erreur
de la colonisation ?
-Certainement, car malgré tout,
ils sont sensibles à ça.
On revient
tout doucement
à certaines traditions.
-Oui.
-Automatiquement,
ils se réaccaparent
ce qu'est leur passé.
-Oui ?
-Il faut leur laisser.
Plus en plus,
y a l'indépendance depuis 60 ans,
mais on vient toujours
un peu donner des leçons.
Or, il faut traiter avec eux,
comme des partenaires,
d'égal à égal.
Gagnant-gagnant.
Et pas dire : "On va vous dire
ce qu'il faut faire."
-C'est toujours le discours
que vous avez tenu
avec les autorités congolaises ?
-Je parle franchement
avec eux, j'ai pas de problème.
-Vous n'avez jamais cherché
à influencer sur le plan politique,
compte tenu
de votre puissance économique...
Le...
le gouvernement, les gouvernements,
congolais ? Jamais ?
-Dans quel sens ?
-En faveur de vos affaires.
-Non.
Ils respectent beaucoup.
Et justement,
les autorités respectent
les gens qui investissent
et qui créent de l'emploi,
qui diminuent la pauvreté
et font du social.
C'est pour ça
que nous sommes respectés
dans toute l'Afrique.
Quand je voyage en Afrique,
je suis respecté, reçu partout
où je vais.
Si je veux,
un chef d'Etat me reçoit.
Notre nom et notre réputation
sont passés outre les frontières.
Donc on n'a pas
de problème là-dessus.
-Que manque-t-il à l'Afrique
pour être plus attractive ?
-On fait une mauvaise publicité
de l'Afrique en Europe.
Toute la presse est toujours contre.
-Les médias sont responsables ?
-En partie.
Et les ONG.
Les ONG aussi,
c'est du business pour eux.
Avec tous les fonds
qu'ils reçoivent,
si vous n'avez pas d'activités
industrielles ou d'affaires,
ils viennent et donnent des aides.
Ils vont acheter pour distribuer.
Apprenons aux gens à travailler
et à produire sur place.
-Vous avez une dent contre les ONG ?
C'est ce que j'ai lu
dans votre livre.
-Y a quelques ONG valables,
mais certaines viennent
et accusent les gens faussement,
rien que pour du business,
c'est tout.
-Vous avez été victime de ça ?
-J'ai été victime.
-Montré
à la vindicte populaire ?
-Non, pas en Afrique,
mais en Europe.
Oui.
-Mmh mmh.
Et donc y a
une mauvaise presse
qu'il faut changer.
Vous essayez
de vous y employer avec ce livre
qui donne une image...
-J'essaye de défendre l'Afrique
parce que je suis un Africain blanc.
-Comme vous l'avez dit.
-Et je crois qu'il est important
que les gens comprennent que
l'Afrique n'est pas ce qu'on veut,
ce qu'on dit,
mais elle est tout à fait différente
quand on la voit
vraiment de l'intérieur,
et voir ce qu'on peut faire.
-Vous avez fréquenté
beaucoup de chefs d'Etat,
de responsables africains.
Quelques-uns d'entre eux
vous ont-il
plus particulièrement
impressionné, marqué,
ou ont suscité votre...
votre sympathie, votre admiration ?
-Quand j'ai fait allusion
au Sénégal, Senghor...
-Léopold Sédar Senghor,
le 1er président
de la République du Sénégal.
-Y avait quand même un pays pauvre.
-Avec peu de richesses en sous-sol.
-Qu'a-t-il fait ?
Il a développé l'éducation.
Il en fait des élites.
Que vous retrouvez aujourd'hui...
-Il est là.
-Que vous retrouvez
dans le monde entier
a des postes importants dans tous
les organismes internationaux.
Et c'est devenu une force.
Aujourd'hui, le Sénégal
se développe très bien.
Il y a Abdou Diouf
que j'admire beaucoup.
-Le successeur de Senghor.
-Un homme remarquable.
-Que tout le monde
remarquait dans les sommets.
-Il était grand
à tous les points de vue.
Ils rient.
C'était quelqu'un
de très bien et qui a quand même
créé la démocratie au Sénégal.
-C'est vrai. Démocratie, oui.
-Quand il était à la francophonie,
il a fait de la francophonie
une force politique importante.
Y avait une certaine influence.
Aujourd'hui,
la francophonie a disparu.
Après le président Diouf,
-Ca n'existe plus ?
-Ca n'existe plus.
-La francophonie,
ça pourrait être
un instrument de développement
qui permet aux pays francophones
d'Afrique
de mieux se développer,
de mieux coopérer entre eux ?
-Y aurait un meilleur dialogue,
avec l'Occident, l'Europe.
-Mmh.
-Je n'ai rien contre le Rwanda,
mais mettre une Anglophone à la tête
de cet organisme, y a un problème.
-Aujourd'hui, la personne
qui est en charge de la francophonie
dans le monde est une Rwandaise.
Et le Rwanda est un pays francophone
à l'origine.
-A l'origine,
mais il est devenu anglophone.
-Ouais.
-La langue officielle chez eux,
c'est l'anglais.
On sent très bien que...
La façon dont les Anglais
ont travaillé avec l'Afrique
était légèrement différente.
Ils donnent moins de leçons.
-La colonisation britannique
a été très différente
de la colonisation
francophone, hein ?
-Comme la colonisation belge,
elle était différente.
-La colonisation belge,
il faut le dire,
très longtemps, le Congo était
la propriété au XIXe siècle,
carrément du roi,
roi des Belges.
-Tout à fait.
Qui a aboli l'esclavagisme.
-Qui a aboli, néanmoins,
l'esclavagisme.
-Qui après a essayé de développer,
a donné le Congo à l'Etat belge.
Et en très peu de temps
en a fait une merveille.
Il faut laisser
à la Belgique ce qu'elle est.
Quand même le Congo,
quand vous pensez qu'en 1960,
elle avait un PIB égal au Canada,
supérieur à la Corée du Sud
et à l'Afrique du Sud.
-Oui ?
-C'est quand même...
-Impressionnant.
C'était quand même
la première puissance
africaine,
après l'Afrique du Sud.
Elle allait dépasser
l'Afrique du Sud.
-Donc tout ça, c'est dû à l'incurie
de ceux qui ont fait
la décolonisation ?
-La Belgique l'a mal préparée.
Faut dire ce qui est.
Elle a construit le pays
avec la base de la pyramide
vers le haut,
mais elle n'avait pas fait
les élites assez tôt,
pour diriger le pays.
Y a eu les troubles
dès l'indépendance,
3-4 jours après, y a eu les émeutes,
la révolution dans le pays.
Tout ce qui était infrastructures,
qui devait rester en place
est parti.
Le pays s'est retrouvé
sans plus personne pour le gérer.
-Ouais.
Vous parliez de culture,
est-ce que vous avez
un artiste préféré en Afrique ?
-J'aime beaucoup Chéri Samba.
-D'accord.
-On l'a beaucoup aidé.
Y a Baloji qui est un photographe.
-Photographe, ouais.
-Ou Serge Kakudji
qui est un contre-ténor.
-Oui.
Vous investissez
dans la culture africaine, en aidant
des artistes ?
-Y en a d'autres qu'on a découverts
qui aujourd'hui
sont de grande réputation.
-Lesquels ?
-Baloji ou Kakudji.
-Ouais.
-Et d'autres qui sont au Canada.
Nous avons une galerie
au musée de Lubumbashi,
qui s'occupe uniquement
de la promotion
des artistes congolais.
-Lubumbashi,
une des grandes villes...
-La 2e grande ville.
-2e ville de la RDC qui est au sud.
-Tout à fait au sud.
-De la République
Démocratique du Congo.
Vos enfants, aujourd'hui,
s'occupent de vos affaires.
Et ils ont la même,
je dirais, le même virus
de la nationalité congolaise
que vous ?
-Je pense qu'ils aiment bien
l'Afrique aussi.
Ils sont là.
Je pense qu'ils sont bien.
Peut-être pas
le même sentiment que moi.
Mais ils restent africains
quand même.
-Oui... Parce que...
Ils sentent
qu'il y a une remise en question
de l'Occident sur place ?
Ils ont quelques craintes ?
-Oui, évidemment, avec tout
ce qui se passe maintenant,
ces systèmes bancaires
et les conditions qu'on met
de plus en plus pour les personnes
qui viennent au Congo.
Ca devient difficile.
Les conditions
d'éthique et d'autres.
On les respecte, mais il ne faut pas
aller dans un extrême.
Y a des choses aussi
qui se passent en Europe.
-Bien sûr.
-Soyons honnête.
-Vous êtes optimiste
pour l'avenir de l'Afrique ?
-Moi, je reste optimiste.
-Vous êtes un afro-optimiste.
-Je suis toujours optimiste
par principe.
Je crois qu'il faut toujours
rêver de quelque chose,
sinon vous ne construisez rien.
-Merci beaucoup.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
"Uncatchable", Alexandr Zhelanov
...